on the final day of the g20 summit
leaders from the world's biggest
economies visited one of rome's most
famous tourist sites trevi fountain
its beauty was one they all could agree
on more difficult was hammering out a
concrete plan to tackle the climate
crisis the final communique
characterized by compromise and vague
language stated that member countries
are committed to reaching net zero
emissions or carbon neutrality by or
around mid-century
they did agree to stop funding the
building of coal plants in poor
countries they set no target however for
phasing out domestic coal use
the italian prime minister who hosted
the summit tried to focus on what he saw
as a success
we managed to keep our dreams alive to
commit to further measures and gigantic
allocations of money further pledges of
reductions and that's the success given
that in recent months it seemed that the
emerging countries in particular had no
intention of making further commitments
british prime minister boris johnson was
clearly disappointed for the group's
failure to make more ambitious
commitments the solution
to climate change is clear
it lies in consigning dirty fossil fuels
like coal to history
in ditching gas-guzzling modes of
transport
and recognizing the role that nature
plays in preserving life on this planet
leaders acknowledged the need to close
the covit 19 vaccine gap by helping to
boost supplies with the goal of
vaccinating 70 percent of the world's
population by mid-2022
important talks took place on the
sidelines sunday
u.s president joe biden highlighted the
environmental benefits of a deal he
announced with the eu that rolled back
trump-era tariffs on steel and aluminum
the united states and the european union
have agreed to negotiate the world's
first trade agreement based on how much
carbon is in a product environmental
groups are concerned that if the g20 a
group of 19 countries in the eu can't
make binding commitments it will be even
tougher for delegates from 200 countries
now meeting in glasgow to agree on
concrete steps to keep global warming at
1.5 degrees celsius
scientists say that's needed to avert
the worst projections of climate
disaster
adam rainey al jazeera rome